for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy
so tetrahydrofolate we mentioned that it
transfers a variety of one car in groups
and we showed them the methylene group
for mole for murray noma phenol and
methyl and we've said that
tetrahydrofolate was important in
transferring intermediately oxidized or
intermediately reduced 1 carbon groups
that's mostly the case right because at
least in the first video we mentioned
just we didn't say mostly but here I'm
just specifying it's mostly the case
because the methyl group is actually the
most reduce that a one carbon group
could be that's not really
intermediately reduced or intermediately
oxidized that's the most reduce but
there's a special deal with that way and
we'll see that later ok now i'm
tetrahydrofolate structure looks like
this ok you might come across it as
tetrahydrofolate acid and that would
just have these carboxyl groups
protonated but it's the same molecule
it's just tetrahydrofolate would be or
started tetrahydrofolate gas it would be
protonated protonated at those positions
so so like I said this is
tetrahydrofolate it's got these tetra
refers to for hydro hydrogen's oops
hydro is hydrogen's and fo later first
the rest of molecules so the four
hydrogen's that we're talking about are
these two green guys and these two blue
guys also this nitrogen here is nitrogen
number 5 and this one is nitrogen number
10 that's important to keep in mind
okay so tetrahydrofolate is also called
THF for h4 folate or f h4 f h4 just
being folate h4 tetra hydro for
hydrogens okay now this can come from
dihydrofolate which only has two of
these hydrogens okay so it's a slightly
more oxidized and that's d hf h2 folate
or f h2 and then down here we've got
folate okay so as far as uh and of
course Bolle has that doesn't have those
two green hydrogens it's it's more
oxidized still
so all of them mostly have the same
structure they all have this this Tara
Dean ring over here and this portion of
the molecule here that's the para amino
benzoate and then this portion over here
that comes from glutamate so one thing I
want to mention is that folate
specifically vitamin b9 often you'll see
folate or folic
just as a term that use is used to
describe or mention all three of these
and so you might see that to be the case
folate or folic - all of these guys but
folate specifically just this one right
here is a vitamin supplement all right
so if you're buying folate or folic acid
as a vitamin it's specifically this guy
right here okay
THF though is found in food that we eat
okay so if you're buying if you're
getting in food you're getting this if
you're getting this in the supplement
form you're getting this now this folate
can be reduced to dihydrofolate by an
enzyme called dihydrofolate reductase
and so that would require specifically a
coenzyme to provide those provide the
reducing power and that is NADPH so
while using NADPH there to reduce it to
dihydrofolate and we'll do that same
thing again to get tetrahydrofolate
again using dihydrofolate reductase it's
gonna reduce dihydrofolate so there's
this question then of how exactly does
this thing this THF that we're talking
about how does this transfer one carbon
units well the one carbon unit that's
going to be transferred will bind to
either the n5 nitrogen the end 10
nitrogen or both of those nitrogens
and is transferred from that position to
the species that's accepting the 1
carbon group and we'll see that actually
in the next video where does that 1
carbon group that gets attached at this
position or at one of those two
positions or both where does that 1
carbon group come from well most of the
1 carbon you
it's come from the carbon that's in
searing sidechain
now of course Syrians an amino acid what
happens is in Syrians conversion to
glycine which of course glycine doesn't
have a carbonated sidechain serine has
one carbon in it side chain THF will
grab syrians side chain and basically
take that one carbon group okay and then
it can convert it into a variety of one
carbon groups that can eventually be
donated you know in different ways so
we'll kind of see how all this works as
far as the one carbon unit how it gets
attached here at this position and how
it's converted into a variety of one
carbon units in the video on conversions
and in fact we in that video i'm not
going to draw this whole portion of the
molecule or the whole molecule what i'm
gonna do is just look at the important
portion when it comes to the one carbon
transfer reactions and that's the
portion bound by these two dotted lines
okay
so just that portion is important
because that has vn5 and antenna at UM's
there where the one carbon group is
going to be that's really what's
important to us when we think about this
guy's a one carbon transfer a cofactor
okay so I hope that video is helpful
thank you for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying